now Eddie whoa was this month the
recipient of the New South Wales local
hero award and was invited to deliver
the New South Wales Australia Day
address last week in Sydney an
incredible young man and I asked him to
join us here in the studio Eddie lovely
to have you so that's what it looks like
see this is another issue because people
look at him and they say oh another one
of these people from China and they've
come here and invaded the countries is a
stack of them tell us your background
you're a dinky-di Ozzy I was born in
camp in our island and I move very far
away to North rocks which is right next
to Parramatta so pretty distant to some
people that are quite local from and
your siblings your new superbugs all
born here in Australia correct and you
know that's why you can hear this accent
coming out of my mouth and those videos
that you pointed out aligned the most
frequent comment is what was that
language he's speaking so it's quite
confusing to people but nonetheless in
that Australia Day address you said you
had great - really growing up you
experienced day-to-day racism you were
harassed and isolated for not being
Australian and you said growing up what
seemed to matter was that I didn't look
Australian or at least I didn't fit what
my peers thought and Australian was
supposed to look like that's tough stuff
isn't it but it's great that you're
talking about it I feel like it's taken
me 20 years to come to the point where
something which was really quite hurtful
and difficult to move through there's
actually something deeply formative for
me and I'm very grateful for having gone
through that experience and being given
the support to understand well this is
not just a unique experience to me
they're actually very common the more
people I speak to the more it resonates
with people how this story is repeated
around the country do you think it's
changed in Australia 2018 the feedback I
get is there's a lot of admiration in
the community for Asians on the basis of
working hard excelling I know at
selective high schools in Western Sydney
that I know reasonably well the top
achievers you look at James ruse and all
those schools the top achievers come
from an Asian background the parents get
the kids into tutoring they-they-they
and thews them they they push them
harder to learning and and then work
hard I mean I think the Australian Way
is the well
come new arrivals and oceans have been
here a long long while but in large
numbers there's recognition of the hard
work the success story and if
Australians have a problem with any new
arrivals its people of blood John the
system and no one says that about the
Asians do you think it's changed a bit
I think it's both changed and stayed the
same I think you point out exactly right
that you know agent migrants have been
here for a very long time I've met a I'm
in a family and they came here I was
about a good 80 years ago so multiple
generations they've been here and in
fact have long forgotten many of the
traditions that would have been
associated with their homeland but you
said a beautiful thing in that speech
you said and I think we should say a
hundred times you said your parents
didn't want you to just live here they
wanted you to belong here hmm
and that was a very deliberate choice in
fact you know going on Saturday mornings
to Chinese school which my brother and
sister who older than me did they
decided not to send me partly because it
was a very hard experience on a Saturday
morning but also because they made a
very calculated choice there I I miss
the fact that I cannot speak the
language that my parents spoke but they
were very deliberately out saying well
this is where we want to invest yeah we
want you to be able to have a command of
the language that we no more Australian
the north rocks I coach the barbarians
as everybody knows really this year
against the Wallabies and we got in the
bus our first match was at Lismore
anybody just piled in the bus and you
set week and I got next to the three
from the front on the left hand side and
this great big man whom I knew played
for Australia Wycliffe par Lou big black
man magnificent back row forward set
next to me we started talking about
everything and it's exactly what you
said I said to Wyclef well where were
you born he looked at me says born in
manly hospital that's what people can't
comprehend decision and I thought how
long did it take you to feel comfortable
that you were indeed a genuine Aussie
decades so I mean as you pointed out 32
and I think it would have been past my
teenage years even into my 20s when I
started to realize okay well he here am
I trained to become a teacher and
realizing that actually I have some
think to give to Australian society and
culture and not just I'm here as a
passenger it really took me that long to
realize okay as a professional I have
something of value too but it's
interesting journey you've had isn't it
because your brother entered the IT
industry and then your sister became a
dentist wildly successful I think you
said that's right the first doctor in
the entire word dynasty and then you
were initially more interested in
English and language and history but you
were convinced that there was a greater
need in the field of mathematics well I
went to the University of Sydney and I
was there standing in the line to enroll
and it was at that moment having done a
reasonable amount of mathematics at
school that one of the professor's
suggested look here is where that not
just a need it's a crying need and it
hasn't changed fifteen years later out
of university if anything it's more
severe and I thought look the thing that
excited me about becoming a teacher was
the opportunity as you've put it out on
the show literally this evening to have
a positive influence on the next
generation one of the leaders of
tomorrow I love what you said I mean I
can understand why you loved English
language he said in the speech Eddie
you're a star he said poetry is the art
of calling the same thing by different
names but mathematics is the art of
calling different things by the same
name just to amplify that okay look so
I'll give you the simplest illustration
that I enjoyed which is that out on the
touch football field I used to be a
touch football coach and we'd you know
it's its fifth and last right we've got
a chance we'll kick the ball off it goes
what path does that ball trace out every
single time as it sails through the air
and the answer is mathematicians call
that a parabola that familiar sort of
arc shape but that's not the only object
that makes a parabola if you take a
comet that's flying around the Sun that
the part that it traces out exactly the
same and I could go on and on and I
could look at logos I could look at
bridges I could look at the path of
water out of a fountain mathematicians
look at very different things and we
understand there's a unity underneath
them you are unbelievable you said this
Australia Day I invite you to become a
mathematician isn't this young man
impressive he said when you look at
people who seem so did
front throughout our country who looked
different you sound different and
believe different things you can be a
mathematician by looking at different
people and calling them all by the same
name Australians beautiful Eddie
God there must be people field to be
taught by you well this is the thing
that I wish I discovered when I was at
school mathematics was taught to me as a
series of steps that you go through to
solve problems and out pops a number and
it took me until university when I
realized that actually mathematics much
like English or history is just a lens
through which you see and perceive the
world and you can understand it in a
ritual way well now come on here we go
tell us it everyone about woo tube five
years ago I had a student he was very
sick and I knew he would be at hospital
getting treatment radiotherapy and
chemotherapy we're gonna keep him away
from school for weeks at a time and
mathematics along with the many other
subjects that mathematics in particular
is a very coherent subject I don't know
if many people have this experience
everything was fine until a certain
point and then if there's a key piece
missing mmm everything after that it's
just great to me sometimes it's
literally great you know and so you know
I knew that this student was going to
have immense trouble getting back on the
horse if it was going to miss all of
those crucial lessons and I figured look
we have technology that enables us to do
something about this and so I began to
film my regular classroom lessons just
with the phone in my pocket this is very
simple technology and I put it on the
internet just to make it accessible to
Hume and I was surprised as much as
anyone else that more than just this one
studio took interest so you stream all
your lessons and now you've got a
hundred and eighty 1000 subscribers and
your videos have been viewed by more
than a million times tell our parents
then how they can access virtue well
actually this is one of the things which
I feel most strongly about which I'd
love to take credit for having planned
but have now very happily come into this
by coincidence parents are one of the
biggest audiences actually of the videos
and I can see there's amazing analytics
behind which tells you the age
demographics of who's viewing and I know
I have children they're four seven and
nine
I definitely understand that feeling of
fear and inability to help your child
when they come home with homework if you
I'm sorry I cannot help you excuse and
so whether it's you know in trigonometry
or you 12 calculus anyone who goes onto
YouTube and searches for for weird tube
or for my name Eddie whoo if it's the
first one that comes up and I've put a
bit of time and effort into arranging
them into playlists that it well
congratulations on your achievement
Eddie a lot of people say oh I did maths
at school and it was no use to me later
in life I always say to my children
maths is a great discipline for getting
your thoughts in order for learning
logic and reason because of the point
you made it's like the links in a chain
you need to be able to progress your
thoughts through in a logical fashion
which I think in this world at the
moment is particularly useful but for
Australia where's that gone wrong for us
in terms of our dropping level on the
international league table in maths and
science we've fallen behind Kazakhstan
that's embarrassing where is it on a
national scale what's been the
difficulty there's a couple of different
factors that need to be weighed in there
the first one is that these
international benchmarks are really
tricky to interpret I mean as an example
if you look at systems across the OECD
and you think about well let's look for
some correlation between systems that do
well and you know their social
circumstances the way their education
system is structured it's actually
immensely challenging to find out to
Gillian useful information out of there
as an example in mathematics there's
been a long raging argument about is the
best way to arrange students in what we
call ability streaming do we separate
out the brightest kids should we take
the people who need more immediate we
separate them out and rank them or do we
have what's called mixed attainment or
mixed ability all the way through you
know let's make sure little Johnny who's
really struggled along is is right next
to Lily who's very good gifted leaving
that there's been a lot of argument that
we use there I mean the after evening
now that one's called vertical
integration where they take the best and
go down the top 20 first class next
twenty next class bottom 20 all together
I don't agree with that I think a
horizontal streaming we have some of the
best some of the not-so-best some of the
mediocre some of the bottom they can
learn from
one another see what I loved about this
you talked about the divisive issues
everywhere and you talked about the
trump president he brings it and local
political issues but then you said this
and Mark and I have talked about this
thousands of times we still haven't
learnt to listen to those around us and
appreciate points of view different from
our own you say this cycle can be broken
and if it is education will be at the
heart of how it happens I mean that's
why people I always say about two ears
and one mouth you've got to listen more
than you speak
absolutely but we're not good at
listening to the other person I had to
make Jim kill and a fillip politician
who once said to me Allen always
remember not all the good players are in
the one team this is why you listen to
another point of view don't you and you
were committed Christian I am so that's
an important part of what I bring to I
mean the this reason I serve the reason
I think it's important to use the gifts
that I have to be able to bring that
value to a community is part of all of
that and I mean teachers are people who
are self sacrificial every teacher that
I know puts in their time and effort
people often say in education it's the
only profession where it's not that you
steal from work to bring in a home you
steal from harm
to bring to work and to serve the
children that are there and that value
of self-sacrifice is definitely deeply
ingrained because of that faith what a
beautiful human being your absolute star
it's lovely to talk to you Eddie Allen's
joining us we'll talk again we must hear
from you again